so welcome to the ohsu informatics
conference we again have our second of
three summer intern presentation
sessions so this is a little longer than
usual because we have three entrance
present they have 15 minutes each with
five minutes for question roughly as you
know our intern program is sponsored by
the National Lab National Library of
Medicine so we're very grateful to their
support over these past five years and
we've had a lot of wonderful interns
come in and we'll have some great
insurance today as well I'm Dave door
vice chair and associate professor of
departments and do we have anybody
actually monitoring the the websites so
maybe we can get doing that usually we
have somebody monitoring you can send
the text hashtag emeis hong co and f2 or
sort of at ohsu of chromatics as the is
the user so if you ask your questions
will try and answer them great so I'm
going to turn it over to the actually
the first mentor just going to introduce
from itching carry I'd like to do Terry
cross Terry's is interning with each new
and myself she's had two projects so
she's gotten to juggle two projects this
summer she's going to be telling you
about an evidence base is situated that
we have created for mammography for
women in their 40s and we also be
speaking with you about curriculum to
pour the disease hi so when I started
this summer I had really expected to
just work with dr. eaten but due to the
unexpected nature of things i was born
in a plan i was able to also sis dr. mom
well so i present you today my tale of
two projects and if dr. you already told
you so the evidence-based decision aid
for research to public use and also
matching clinical informatics curriculum
to four
let's start project the first so my work
with dr. eaten the summer involved
updating and revising a decision aid am
I going to went to a lot of detail but
decision aids are most probably familial
does but briefly the memo pad is a
breast cancer screening decision aids it
was designed for average risk women and
authorities and it was sort of divided
into three separate components the first
component is the risk assessment and
this is where the users start out to
determine whether or not they're of
average risk they have to answer a
series of questions and this is based on
risk screening that was developed by dr.
cecilia del cross back in 2009 so if
they are above average risk what happens
is they get exited out of the app and
our advice to seek further information
from their health care whether the
second component is information crazy
and this gives the users information
about the risk of breast cancer and it
also gives them some kind of an insight
into what to expect when they first go
in for their first mammogram final
pieces values assessment and this is
where they can kind of determine with
their own personal values are in regards
to the like the benefits or the arms of
mammograms and kind of brings in that
whole personal issue the final takeaway
if a report that they are presented with
in the form of the PDF and the users can
take this information within and when
they notice is that their provider and
it prepares them to have that discussion
on what options work best for them
regarding when to start their vemma
grams feeding this this app basically
addresses the controversy that experts
are not in agreement on when
average-risk women in their forties
should start with their screening the
doctors and clinicians they're basically
faced with a lot of conflicting
recommendations and makes it difficult
for them to know what advice to give
their patients this tool addresses that
by first and as you saw the risk
assessment to women and then guiding
them to efficient that they could make
this right then now back in inning a
summer dr. Dean and I did meet with
representatives for the Center for
Women's Health to discuss steps and put
implementing this tool into the clinic
one of the first suggestions that they
wanted was to see branding in other
words TV ohsu love a clip on to several
of the pages in the app as well along
the violin for PDF I also need you to go
through and remove any remaining
research text that was left over from
the tree search page there were a couple
comments about seeing the research
coordinators so I have to make sure
those work take it out I also wanted to
include a hotline so some women who
might need either uninsured or
underinsured for them to call and the
resource that I had on was for the
breast and cervical cancer program this
is a public health program that women
can call to find out if they're eligible
and if so it gives them information on
local providers that offer free stream
so we also wanted to include a
disclosure page the disclosure page
tells basically who the developers were
and if there was any conflict of
interest it explains kind of the process
that was gone through the development of
the app and it also talks about when we
had to include this when the update
is it also explains the intended users
of the app and so this is going to be
put into the app it's not in there right
now but we're at that point just going
ahead and getting it put in the final
piece is trying to get it to get it
verified by the international patient
decision aids standards so there was a
checklist that was put out by if dog and
I took this checklist to kind of matched
it up to what the app does now and one
of the interesting things that we found
right often that there was 11 of being
criteria that really didn't apply to the
mammal pad does one of the examples is
using patient stories so when we took
out those 11 not with all criteria and
with the changes that we're making right
now we feel like we're going to be able
to meet a percent of the chemical
criteria and hopefully get this done
fruit so looking forward to this app we
have heard from Providence and they seem
to be interested there's going to be
think of meeting set up soon to get a
demo and hopefully those overlap and
we're still kind of waiting to hear back
from the Center for Women's Health and
it also is possible for it to be used in
some of the orbit clinics which is where
some of the researchers started out at
this time I'd like to move on to my
second summer project project second now
when I first enrolled in the informatics
program at Portland Community College I
wasn't real sure what to expect there
but based on the curriculum it seemed to
me the digit definition of informatics
was basically just electronic health
records and it wasn't really until I
started here that I kind of saw this big
broader view of what if biomedicals mad
so what are the competencies american
medical informatics
designed that of Informatics that I want
to be cool thank you but you can see by
their definition that this is a really
broad scope it covers a lot of different
specialties but all of us have
specialties all share certain basic
fundamental skills and those skills have
been developed into core competencies
those can be used to build a focused and
more standardized curriculum for
colleges and the Commission for
accreditation for health informatics and
information is where that started out
and I think that now they're working
with a mia to for the refinement in here
in 2009 dr. regarder took some of these
competencies and further refined them he
broke them into four different
categories the first is the fundamentals
which is kind of all the basic
information about informatics itself
second the clinical decision making sure
process so this is all the evidence
based care and clinical decision making
food he informatik the health
information systems that's basically all
the technical stuff and then finding the
leadership and management so things like
the implementation leading the change to
the limitation and maintenance at
regions here with you now probably they
offer a few different degree programs
there's the master of science there's
the master biomedical informatics and
graduate certificate and over time these
these different programs need to evolve
in order to stay current with all of the
changes and technologies and as we
discover the new uses for biomedical
data so it kind of presented this
problem where we need to go back
periodically and review the curriculum
to ensure that we're still meeting those
four criteria for company I started out
with this by becoming a server status of
these classes and that gave me access to
all of the wealth of course content
so I had to be enrolled in previous
boxes and concurrent at that point what
i would do is just systematically go
through all the course materials week by
week so it's like reading the reading
lecture notes actually sometimes
watching some of the lectures the one
with online presentations and are they
articles and some of the reading i was
actually able to find a few of the folks
that were required that were available
online i used a checklist that was
developed three years ago as a
spreadsheet and all I was doing was
making sure that in the content that it
was confirming if it was met in the
courses or maybe if it was not there I
just didn't see it I also found that
there were a few places that were not
previously covered that looked like it
was fading included this when i first
got explained to us it seemed like a
pretty straightforward really found that
it took much longer than I anticipated
there's a lot of content and it's also
really difficult to decide if the
competencies are being met or not
because sometimes in one of the lectures
or readings that would see a keyword but
what actually dig through and read
through it it's not really covering it's
not really explaining or defining it
look very well so it's kind of hard to
decide that the next step would be to
contact some of the instructors and kind
of confirm within if they feel that this
is being covered their horses or not
this thought this process was time
consuming and yes juggling two projects
sometimes busy for my summer started out
kind of slow quickly i found myself very
busy so i thought this is a great maybe
think what my family probably saw me the
last few weeks so i just want to say i
really appreciate the the chance to work
with dr. eaten it's really exciting to
see how her decision aids moving forward
and i also really want to appreciate
ever say thank you to dr. mom for giving
me a chance to see the program
HTC offers and to see all of the various
aspects that are you know the expanding
areas of bioinformatics I also like to
give things to Lindy Watson for giving
me some advice system are given support
also the people at ohsu Sakai this was
the online pro program and I'm telling
these people were great when I bracketed
anything they they were right on it I
really appreciate that I'd also like to
thank all of the people at device for
giving me the summer and force my fellow
interns I think there were the second
group that i'm not sure that they're
going to want to do I have one okay what
was the coverage that we had in that in
our classes of course at a class of an
inch the competencies was it pretty good
yeah pretty good there was there's a few
and again the beginning forces were a
lot more that covered a lot more because
they were all like that basic knowledge
and stuff so dr. Bishop class of course
covered tried a bit and he was great
because i was able to send in the email
and kind of point out things I couldn't
find he was either said yes I am no I
don't cover so it was really great it's
challenging to have to email instructor
and say you know I don't think you're
covering is respected you you have that
hey this is important you know if i'm
not that i'm not i need to need to
reflect that in it because curriculum
does change folks change yeah so i also
just a comment is that for the first
part of your presentation we had a
webinar this morning
the comprehensive primary care
initiative so that's 60 ecstasy state
clinics in oregon now required in the
decision aid and of the six mostow's we
mentioned decision aids being one city
days was by far the hardest one
prevention and the one day and to stay
having ongoing difficulties sorry can't
appreciate that both what you found that
Senator one South sort of a stir these
changes and then are like well we don't
quite remember a quite ready to put it
in and and that you know this aspect
it's important to getting a lot of
patients the client service riveting
well and I was supposed to dr. he did
share with me the fact that just
something simple like putting a no
agency logo she said that was a very
complicated process behind the scene she
was dealing with as far as filling out a
lot of paperwork and wife and things
only to come to find out that oh you
just want the logo go ahead so I mean
there's all of these little didn't used
to walk pretty good it's very exciting
I'm really glad to see it hopefully this
comment any other questions
introduced so i'm michael chang and i
have the pleasure of introducing emily
over here for those of you who don't
know emily she is going to be a senior
at university of washington in the fall
and she's studying public health she's
been a real pleasure to work with here
Emily's so we work with a big group of
collaborators from around the country in
different areas Emily's been a really
really good team player it worked well
with everybody she's also done a good
job of learning things independent
taxable and yeah
so on the group that I worked with deals
does a lot of work involving a disease
called retinopathy of prematurity ROP
and specifically we work on technologies
like Calvin Edison can computer based on
internal assess and Emily had some
projects at dealt with various aspects
how bad that she'll be talking about
alright so Emily Emily a second
population
and I had the pleasure working with dr.
michael chang summer focusing on how to
optimize diagnostic resources right now
new york attorney question how many of
you recognize the man in this photo cope
with it clear whether yeah exactly know
how many of you know why he's blind 147
stevie wonder's flag actually because
something known as retinopathy of
prematurity also known as our okie i'll
be talking about this case more later on
in this presentation but first a brief
overview i'll be presenting on what r LP
is the importance of pell medicine is
making correct diagnosis for ROP my role
here the summer working with specific
data set and then building a website
while all this matters and finally again
my experience here we just do the summer
so retinopathy of prematurity is a
disease that specifically affects
premature infants in there right now and
specific those who are under 32 weeks
around two and a half pounds or less
around two and a half pounds here going
to see you about two-thirds about the
obvious obscure
sorceries about two-thirds develop some
40 feet thankfully those cases will
regress spontaneously on their own
unfortunately attends one of those cases
well come severe enough to require
treatment and could unfortunately each
appliance risk factors again include
those who are born really premature
steer the underweight and steven high
oxygen content which was the case for
Stevie Wonder and back in 1950s but not
know that it would affect abilities and
unfortunately let's move on planets when
diagnosing rfe one important factor is
is in here at ohsu is using telemedicine
so first 40 teeth the opthamologist need
something called the alcohol no scope to
look in the back of the eye and then
observe what's going on exactly and
after after observing thigh will write
on this image right here of paper kind
of just what they saw I notice you
really lucky to be using some a tool
called the right camp image to hear that
allows the center should to take still
images of the eye and then use that for
later comparison for their own diagnosis
and watch the progress of that infant
and see how the developing or six is
hopeful if there are 0 he goes way when
diagnosing rfp therefore very important
parameters to make a holistic diagnosis
including zone stage + disease and then
finally the severity of disease and his
treatment will be required songs first
thing to measure how far out the blood
vessels growing from the eye if you see
on this top edge here zone one zone to
zone three the further out the blood
vessels the better this image here is
healthy I of an infant and you can see
that the blood vessels going fully
outward towards the end of the eye the
second category to look at in stage on a
scale from one to five here when what
happens when the blood vessels don't
grow up fully is that this whitey mark
ations line grows perpendicular of blood
vessels might be hard to make out the
first image but imagine I doctor school
as well so you can see here that there's
a white line up here you can stage one a
white line here in stage 2 greater
severity this fridge stage 3 and
stage 4 when reached business agree to
stage three thousand treatment well you
can't require and unfortunately to or to
avoid unfortunate cases like this where
the right now is almost is completely
detached from the eye and we not in
typical desi complex the third and
possibly most important part perimeter
and diagnosing ROP something called
Plessis which looks at the overall
tortuosity or squiggly pneus of the
blood vessels you can see in this image
here the blood vessels are very curvy
and dilated which when indicates that
this infant here has Plessis however
that community difficult to diagnose
month collisions so if you look in these
blockages here this is where at omed
ascending peter banks image analysis
comes in handy it's very important in
helping diagnose RRP here specific
design statements from the blood vessels
of a certain cases taken and then you
can look at the division of the length
and then the angle blood vessel and then
the quantitative score on something that
is otherwise qualitative so for example
if you have high blood pressure if
you're above a certain number you have
my blood pressure hopefully with the
band's computer-based image analysis
will be able to put objective
quantitative score on something that can
otherwise be qualitative and status
which is illustrated in this image here
and you love between the 21 experts who
diagnose this I have nearly half steps
left and then half said not that makes
it very difficult to know if the
entities to be treated for ROP or not
which is sort of where my role came in
the summer folks who wants to the data
side in the states that I was given the
diagnosis of 887 subjects and looking at
comparison of two experts who looked at
all these images for all the four
categories for each eye and then
comparing that with clinical diagnosis
when looking at this data set measure
one thing called kappa statistic which
basically takes a green men and accounts
for the chance it counts for chance so
here's the liberals from what we found
but using trying to open kappa
statistics if you can see i change the
data set so it was binaries either
stage 3 or not zone one or not plus or
not and the treatment prior or not when
you look at the observer percentages
throw up quite high Muslim about ninety
percent which would indicate very strong
agreement but then when you look at the
Casa statistics they're not quite as
high demonstrating that experts buyers
and variability can really kind of show
that diagnosing RP is much more
difficult because our percentages are
time changes for experts you look at
expert wonders of sex for to the much
higher in agreement between this expert
wanting clinical and then x 42 in
clinical this is what demonstrates
telemedicine is very important showing
that expert raider agreement is
important understanding how when just
looking at images are okay can be
diagnosed versus the time that you're at
the bedside looking at RP an infant and
then so this is kind of where my second
goal came in the summer of trying to
take all this information and then how
can we relate us and my second job here
was taking this information say from
this data set and then building a
website which we known as Arab calm
which will be a great repository of
images and different data sets to show
experts researchers and clinicians how
to better learn about diagnosing ROP and
what are opiates this is also very
important because here go just you we're
very lucky to have hesitated specifies
RP ophthalmologist that's not the case
in other hospitals in rural areas or
other countries and a happy website like
this for having a website in general
that can be accessed internationally the
goal is that people across from cars can
learn more about RP and how to make more
quantitative correct diagnosis amongst
different experts so I made the website
using a couple tools first bootstrap
which is a great fun and frameworks
source that can be great for using
mobile devices and then Rockets text
visible here the first is from HTML and
CSS in addition some JavaScript so you
go from something like this so that is
something like this here's will be with
what the preliminary idea of the home
page will look like that way clinicians
researchers and other people can access
database text to compare images and see
where the discrepancies are occurring
for example when you go to some of the
pages you'll have something like this
showing that expert 1 at X / to agree to
disagree in almost all of these various
by looking at this I so it's incredibly
important trying to learn about and
understand where the discrepancies
occurring and what information can you
take away from that thought we were
correct items you can be made for
infants with ROP a gift treatment will
be required now you'll need be wondering
why does this matter bacala Stevie
Wonder's one in 1950 not many premature
infants survived but with the
advancement of medicine now more
premature infants are surviving and with
that there's increased incidence rate of
ROP p.m. this has many economic impacts
and different impacts of outs just
overall understanding how to prep the
diagnose our keys and finding ways to
increase overall greater agreement
between experts as I mentioned before
this is incredibly important when you're
looking at places in emerging countries
or places rural areas where you don't
have any ROP specialist to make
diagnosis by using something like the
red cam images can then be taken from
say the nurse and then can be sent to
specialists through the web and then
diagnosis can be made to decide if the
infant eat Street they're not which has
got a great way to have that website
open is to have a good model for how are
we should be diagnosed and how where the
screens are occurring and then the cells
focus on the accuracy of diagnosis when
looking at again the percent agreement
its high between experts but you don't
always have an expert making that
diagnosis so that's why it's important
to have something like this website and
then use information from that data sets
looks where should research going
further into better dynamic a ROP the
roll-ups may talk about my experiences
here at ohsu probably one of my favorite
parts was the
able to go with dr. Chang into the NICU
and observe just how everything's being
used how he's making these diagnoses
using that phone the scope and then
watching how the wreck hand were to take
these images I actually seeing the
progress of the infant's over following
beats and seeing if there are P has
hopefully regressed or unfortunately two
times for the dip request my time heroes
will able to learn a lot programs
including art a statistical analysis
bootstrap and then using yep using ours
in boots job and then you know coming
before I came here actually I started
out originally with a pre-law I analysis
changed as you can tell more interested
in informatics and think of this
internship has done a great job showing
what to do with a huge amount of
information and where does your role
committed working as an intern at
assists in a hospital I came here kind
of with the idea naive idea that I was
mostly just found by doctors which is
obviously not the case and seeing how
people of all different specialties and
areas of expertise can work together to
make you know take for a common goal or
cause like I repeat and the fact I just
like to give a special thanks to working
with dr. Cheng had a great summer and
with our study coordinator soon not
smell and the rest of the okapi team
jaishree Peter Paul and Michael and then
a special thanks to follow it turns
Jesse for being a great office buddy and
then for really hoping teaching out of
the car and just old fellow teammates
interns and everyone involved
work you know this why the website
hopefully soon as an accident but I have
a question yeah so I think that it's
really interesting to see the ways in
which experts disagree on when you were
beginning your project did you run
across or encounter anything in your
initial understanding of the research
for ways to maybe start automating some
of these diagnoses through like software
that just takes images that the
computers come for the eyes saying you
know here is a positive diagnosis and
how that might compare the expert
opinion yeah that's what some of the
other work is being done by the ROP team
beyond Harry's ohsu and they're looking
at different ways like periods and
analysis to give like quantitative
scores and but with expert agreement to
it's showing that even when we have high
agreement that's still showing
demonstrating the importance of
telemedicine so using something like
that i can and allow people like nurses
to make take the guy to take the images
and then have here's the doctor to make
the diagnosis
all right Vince getting his slide up
high and actually the interdictor for
Ben Neely we're very glad to have him
this summer he's actually our second
insurance he went last week and gave a
great presentation Ben is actually
earned his undergraduate degree already
and so is actually actively looking for
work after this internship you know it'd
be fantastic to work with very
quantitative and and skilled already so
he'll talk about how he uses skills in a
couple different projects thank you
thank you emily and thank you terry for
your excellent presentations and thank
you all for taking the time to be here
today i'm going to be talking about
cases for dating utilization and
analysis primarily with the top med and
CPC studies but i'd like to start out
with a quote one of my favorite
statisticians john to pee who's a
pioneer of some of the modern methods
that we use today he said the best thing
about being a statistician is that you
get to play in everyone's backyard this
really rings true for my experience here
at ohsu this summer I came in with an
experience in research being very
academic and very task driven but on my
first day I sat down and I met with dr.
Gork and he told me if you feel lost and
you have no idea what you're doing
you're probably on the right track this
opened my eyes to a different way of
doing research more exploratory research
method and it also gave me the
opportunity to play in some of these
different backyards the first of which
being taught med top med stands for
transforming outcomes for patients
through medical home evaluation and
redesign it was a study using some
principles primarily high-value elements
from the medical home program this is an
oregon-based program but it's
programs being developed throughout the
United States now high value element is
a predetermined area where you can get
the most bang for your buck so to speak
how you can improve the functioning and
the quality of clinical practices while
reducing costs these elements were
predetermined before the beginning of
the top med program and therefore
implemented in top men this was a
program that was conducted throughout
the past few years in eight oregon-based
clinics in a cluster randomized
controlled trial design now what that
means is that each clinic acted as a
cluster or each clinic received either
an intervention for a controlled
treatment child described voluntarily
the physicians therefore within each
clinic practice and try to follow the
standards based on the intervention or
the control which they were signs with
this is a general overview thank you
doctor door for this graphic of the
intervention and control methods or
parts of the study the intervention
being incentives with a multiplier focus
practice support rapid cycle IT approved
again these were based on very specific
high value of elements on the other hand
the control was based on elements that
the clinic's themselves determined to be
important and then set relevant goals
for these included safe incentives
though lacking the multiplier general
practice support and the same IT
components I'll now go through and sort
of break each of those things the
incentives were obviously monetary
because few things motivate people more
than money with the control group the
money that they were allocated was based
on how well they set and followed up on
their goals it was one lump sum based on
those criteria with the incentives and
multiplier in the intervention group
this was broken down a little bit
further most of the money came for the
same reason however there was a portion
that was also attributed with a
multiplier determining how much of that
proportion they got that was also based
on continuing follow-up and on further
developing their goals this allowed
those in the intervention
to earn a slightly larger incentive thus
promoting the idea of following these
high-value element based goals the focus
practice of work again was a high
contact between those conducting the top
med study and each of the clinics
involved in the intervention seeing how
they were doing with their goals
offering support and offering ideas for
that how they could better reach them
the rapid cycle ite improvement was
constant feedback and constant
improvements to the IT systems that they
were using now we did want to deprive
any clinics of any valuable information
so the IT between control and
intervention groups was largely the same
but those of the intervention group had
access to tier rankings and to see where
they stood as far as their success in
the program thus falling now when I came
into the product most of the data had
already been gathered and analysis had
started unfortunately we were getting
some kind of anomalous and discrepancies
we were looking at the data from a
clinical level trying to match up how
many patients were in each clinic based
on the all pair all claims or a pack
data set which is an oregon-based data
set but again contains all payers and
all claims versus the number of patients
that we knew were attributed to each
clinic and each provider based on
electronic health records I want to draw
your attention to the last line here in
this table those are the percent these
are calculated by looking at the number
in the claims the number of patients and
dividing that by the number that we know
are associated with each provider in the
electronic health records and you'll
notice there are a couple that are over
a hundred percent this hinders our
analysis and stands out as a red flag
this is something that we need to
correct now there are difficulties
associated with this namely that the all
payer all claims data set is
de-identified we don't know which
patients Sauvage doctors specifically we
know which clinic they went to but we
can't identify these patients
them up directly and so it was my job to
come in and match based on the provider
find out how many individuals or
patients each provider was seeing and
then compare that to the old pair of
claims data set in order to do this I
use a two-step matching process in are
based on unique identifiers the first of
which being NPI or national provider
identification this is a number that's
assigned to each practitioner of
Medicine during the accreditation
process it's a unique identifier but
it's not perfect there were occasions
where this number was missing in the
records where it was entered incorrectly
or if it was just altogether wrong so
when we when I matched based on the NPI
I got about 75% magic which is better
than nothing but not sufficient to clear
up these results either one ended a
second level of matching based on EHR
provider ID which again is a unique
identifier based on the electronic
health records using that I was able to
match all but two of the providers
enabling us to continue on with our
analyses this is a subset of the table
which was fairly large that shows some
of the percentages again calculated the
same way as the clinic based percentages
though on a provider level and you can
see some of these percentages are
ridiculous we got as high as 160 1000
percent of patients being visited by any
one position or visiting any one
physician there are a number of
different reasons this could be occurred
the physician could be working in other
clinics patients could be miss
attributed to a physician at seven
however this is still important to make
note and so after discussing the doctor
door we made some exclusion criteria for
which providers to include on which to
exclude after developing these criteria
we were able to reevaluate the data at a
clinic level and reduce the percentages
to something much more realistic thus
enabling us to continue with further
analysis we're now going to jump into
another back yard with CPC or
comprehensive primary care this program
is similar to top met in that it seeks
to improve
health care while reducing costs but the
methods are a little bit different CPC
focuses on delivering value based care
rather than volume based care so that
physicians are paid and incentivized
based on the health of their patients
rather than on the number of services
that they perform this encourages
preventive care and proactive care and
therefore the overall health of the
patient population now CPC was run of
the past few years in several ohsu
clinics and in other places and so it
was my opportunity to come in during one
of the review period after nine quarters
of CPC I was tasked with developing a
way to look at these two progress thus
far of CPC and see how we're doing
whether or not it's having a positive
impact on these clinics on quality
measures and on expenditures they've
asked me to create SPC charts or
statistical process control charts for
this purpose now I was unfamiliar with
this and this is kind of a unique use of
SVC charts typically they're used for
manufacturing processes in which you
look at product quality over time to
determine whether or not there are large
gaps and variants and quality but this
is also a great way for identifying any
patterns for points that stick out and
looking at how a trench develops over
time these are a few examples of some of
the SPC charts I created I ended up
creating around 15 of these but for the
purpose of this presentation I will
focus on these three the x-axis on each
of these charts is broken up into the
quarter the first four values you'll
notice are negative and those indicate
the run in time or the four quarters
prior to the beginning of CPC the
subsequent nine quarters are those
quarters in which the clinics were
practicing under the CPC guidelines the
y-axis represents a proportion of
hospitalizations this is defined as the
number of hospitalizations per patient
per order the points represent the
averages of those patient visits of
those proportions for each of those
quarters you'll notice some
points are different colors a black
point is just a regular point a yellow
point represents a possible trend that
may be of interest and I'll explain that
in a moment whereas a red point
represents something that's outside of
norm and potentially statistically
significant you'll notice there are 2
dashed lines those represent the upper
and lower confidence levels anything
within those confidence levels we
consider normal it's not different from
that center line or that average which
we would expect with this first graph is
large one you'll notice that there's a
series of points that are all above that
center line that's why there are some
points that turn yellow / saying hey we
expect these to be bouncing back and
forth around that confidence line as if
there was random variables this may
indicate that our confidence or our
center line needs to be a little bit
higher a little bit closer that so that
we're more accurately accurately
representing the trend the points
outside which I suppose again that are
statistically significant in this case
these are below the lower confidence
level indicating that they're
significantly lower than our expected
average and this is good we can see the
overall trend is decreasing suggesting
that CDC had a positive impact in
reducing the number of hospitalizations
in clinics a through C but we can break
yourself even further rather than just
looking at an aggregate of three
different clinics we can look at
individuals I've only selected two of
the three that were included again for
the sake of time you'll notice that with
clinic a all of those points are within
our confidence levels there's nothing
unusual these are all fairly close to
the attitude which we were expecting but
if we look at vanak be both before and
after CTC we see some extreme values
this suggests that clinically might have
a greater impact on the overall trends
that we're seeing as far as
hospitalizations are concerned now the
nice thing about being a statistician is
we get to present data
we get to explain the world through
numbers and through visualizations but
it's important that we have effective
tools to do this another part of
creating these SVC charts was to make
them publicly available to make sure
that people had access to this
information so that improving health
care can be a shared goal for all in
doing this I was asked to create a shiny
application shiny is an R script based
application builder that also uses some
elements from HTML it's a great way to
deliver interactive customizable data
visualization experiences I will now put
through into a demonstration of the
shiny hat which I built for this project
internet loading times pen
now the first thing you'll notice is
that this is just showing the same plots
but you saw earlier the difference being
that now we can select exactly what we
want to see and we have access to more
information we can select specifically
which class we are interested in as well
as the quality measures that we are
interested in here we have
hospitalizations hospital readmissions
and emergency department visits and
again this information is available for
each of the clintons now these have been
di identified so is not to promote or
hinder the development of any other
projects or cause any legal concerns but
these do represent the actual results
from CPC and so this is a valuable
learning information LCBC empty CPC is
ongoing you're still gathering data from
subsequent quarters and it will be
included in both the shiny ax and in
future publications this allows us to
expand the shiny out to further develop
our communication tools and to include
more quality measures such as
cost-effectiveness top med concluded and
we recently gathered more data from all
parallel plates the results of that are
forthcoming and therefore we can expect
to see how this succeeded and where that
will go in the future shortly finally
I'd like to make some acknowledgments to
the D my Steam to David oh yeah Doug
Jesse Lindsey melody Roger shall we
Stephen and Tracy special thanks to
Stephen he was my cubicle matin helps
keep me safe through some of the more
difficult programming tasks than to
Katrina Ramsay on the biostatistics team
for helping me with the analysis and
formatting and to my fellow informatics
interns who provided me with great
feedback and networking opportunities
thank you and will now open up for
questions
yeah so in the ECC project I it seems
for both clinic be and the aggregates of
a TRC you begin to see the trend go
outside the confidence intervals around
the seven in quarter or so Germany I
preliminary intuitions or ideas why so
late in the in the trend you might start
to see some sort of difference well when
you're implementing a clinic wide
practice it takes time to develop the
ideas and to make sure that they're
being carried out at every level of the
organization as far as the general
hypotheses for why those are the
particular trends we're seeing I'm
actually meeting with some of the
clinicians to talk about developing
hypothesis test exporters picture yes I
want to be in terms of fiction other
questions
all right